I was 11 years old when I put myself in
a foster care it kind of came to a
breaking point around when I turned 11
there was a lot of physical fights there
was a lot of just emotional abuse I just
kept having issues with my dad we never
got along we had always butt heads and
then he started dating his cousin which
was a little a little weird for me I
ended up calling the kids help phone I
told them that I was depressed that I'm
having all these issues in my home and
that I couldn't take it anymore and I
needed to get out then the police came
and then I got taken away and put into
foster care I first went into a girl's
home I feel like we should take home out
of girls home my stuff would get stolen
all the time I would get beat up I ended
up at a cucumber farm with Mennonites I
ended up with a very very religious
family so I felt like I was just sort of
an extra in their movie I was just like
an extra in their life I had it up at a
bunch of different homes but I didn't
find anything very permanent there was
really nowhere to go I moved out just
before I turned 17 I was in high school
and I was working full time I still had
a little bit of monthly support from the
children's days but as soon as I turned
21 they cut off all benefits I lost
everything I had
[Music]
you're just starting like one of the
biggest parts of your life and then now
you're just like shoved to the side and
unimportant
I remember repeatedly going into
negative in my bank account I just paid
my rent and then I didn't have any money
for food I couldn't afford toilet paper
[Music]
you
[Music]
I feel like youth who are aging out of
foster care you don't have the financial
training they don't have the emotional
support and it's a no wonder they're
they're ending up homeless and they're
ending up not graduating high school not
going to college not getting a proper
education and ending a broke
what up Fox family I just think that if
there's anyone like going through this
like anyone that's going through being a
youth that's about to eat out of foster
care that's aging out of foster care
there is you know thousands of other
people that are going through the same
thing as you you're not alone
[Music]